I think Bitcoin has a PR problem
sustainability greater in 2020
not green problem agree disagree
completely disagree gone so I think the
big thing we have to remember is this is
the most secure computing network in the
world right so it is going to take
electricity or power consumption in
order to power that security but the
beauty of it is the miners this
decentralized group of people who are
financially incentivized to provide that
security through computing power they
have to go find the cheapest power
sources right that's how they make money
is that there's a spread there for them
and so ultimately what they're gonna do
is seek out cheap energy sources which
is renewable energy and so what we tend
to see around the globe is yeah what we
just did we've seen people looking for
the cheapest power which is renewable
power thankfully when it comes to a lot
of renewable power sources there's
excess power generation that can't be
stored somewhere right so it's obviously
one of the big problems is the battery
issues I'm the uncertainty with it you
can't have consistent energy power
whether it's hydro or wind or whatever
it is that we're talking about though so
you can't store solar energy so
efficiently either so I absolutely the
drawbacks here so one of the things you
can't store it and then also on top of
that you get infrequent demand spikes
right so it's not always persistent
demand when it comes to Bitcoin mining
all of a sudden now if I have a
renewable energy source I don't have to
worry about storing all that power
because I can just install more machines
and I have a persistent demand at all
times I can always have my machines
running consuming power and securing
this blockchain so we've seen is this
explosion of hash rate on the Bitcoin
blockchain continuing that trend of it
being the most secure in the world but
it's using renewable power rather than
kind of non renewables that are more
expensive to actually produce there's
two arguments there there's one that
look this is the most secure option that
people have out there if they come to
understand that and therefore there is
some compensation there is an energy
cost to that
and in efficiency cost of that in terms
of energy but you also told me that
around 70 75 percent of the energy being
used right now is renewable where that
data coming from because there's fierce
criticism when I look around the world
and China of course we know they're not
clean yes there's a lot of studies that
have come out you know I'm the first to
admit that each study every one can pick
and choose what they like out of it they
don't like that etcetera the general
consensus in those studies is 60 to 80%
right so call it 70 75 % 60% 80%
whatever the number is it's much more
than people think is renewable right and
on top of that where we see dollars
flowing from the investment community is
into these renewable based solutions
right so whether it's things around
hydro solar you know I've talked a lot
people about using nuclear power plants
they have excess power generation they
can't store it we'll all of a sudden if
it's actually cheaper and cleaner to use
could you start to use the nuclear power
there's a lot of options but the best
part about this is there's a financial
incentive for miners to figure out how
to innovate in this space because if
they are the leaders there is a very
very big payoff at the end of it will it
ever be less energy intensive I mean
I've got some comparisons here it was a
report done last year the comparable
carbon footprint of Bitcoin mining is
New Zealand's electrical energy use
comparable to the power consumption in
in Chile a waste generation comparable
to Luxembourg nation states in terms of
energy consumption here and and carbon
footprint can it improve that or you're
saying it doesn't matter it doesn't have
to do as long as it's renewable energy
that's being used I think it's two
things right so one is renewable makes
that story very different than if it
wasn't it does and then second is
because it's the most secure computing
network in the world again you expect it
to have that high energy consumption but
the hardware is also changing so what
you're seeing is much more energy
efficient Hardware coming into the
market so whether it's through chip
designs or other hardware innovations
again it just takes time to do this
right there's real engineers working
with hardware and there's atoms evolved
and you just have to do scientific work
to figure this out we've seen over the
last 11 years it improved I don't think
that that'll stop it's just how quickly
can they innovate